they needed to bail out the second  largest bank in Cyprus in order to do  that They confiscated the money of  people who had over a hundred thousand  Euros in the bank I Think They  confiscated around 45 or maybe 47 and a  half percent I can't fully remember the  number um of their money so people woke  up one day to have their money gone  because those are the top made terrible  calls the second largest bank needed to  be bailed out and so people had to pay  for it and that is disgusting They  confiscated their money money is the  energy which fuels your life without  freedom of money you have freedom of  nothing that's why I'm forever bullish  on bitcoin and I definitely think it's  going to go back on when the bull run  hits and I think that will be from 2024  onwards after the halving event